♪♪
Lizzie and I love dogs more than
anything.
Charles:
And that's why we're going to
help as many dogs
Charles:
as we can find their forever
homes.
♪ Time flies by
in the yellow and green ♪
♪ Stick around and you'll
see what I mean ♪
He's so cute!
Oh, believe me, he knows it.
♪ There's a mountain top
that I'm dreamin' of ♪
When you need to chew, use
this.
♪ I'll be riding shotgun
underneath the hot sun ♪
The one thing heroes have in
common is helping others.
(Dog barks)
Dogs need us to take care of
them and be their heroes.
♪♪
All she needs is a lot of PLC.
You mean TLC?
No, PLC: Patience, love,
and consistency.
♪ I'll be riding shotgun ♪
When we're trying to find a
home for a puppy, you never give
up.
♪♪
Lizzie:
I can't do it without you.
We have to work together.
♪ I'll be riding shotgun
underneath the hot sun ♪
He sure looks happy now!
♪ Someone, someone,
some... ♪
(Puppy whines)
Not so much now.
♪ I 'll be riding shotgun
underneath the hot sun ♪
♪♪
Can you believe this used to be
a dolphin?
(Puppy whines)
♪♪